joining me here on the rich eisen show
uh is uh an all-pro tight end
and an all pro human being um who gave
to run rich run this year he said i want
to be part of your run i offered him to
be part of the run
he said i will be part of the run i mean
i'm by the way paraphrasing this is not
the way it
did not sound like a dr seuss book when
we had this conversation
uh but he has been pissed to use the
stewart scott phrase
uh he is the tight end of the san
francisco 49ers you're defending nfc
champion 49ers he is george
kittle here on the rich eisen show how
are you george rich how you doing this
morning man
you know what the last time we saw each
other was in indianapolis and you said
to me when you brought you
on behalf of you and your lovely wife a
check for ten thousand dollars to run
rich run
you said to me you leaned over to me you
said my ear he said you got my first big
check
and i said to you i think it's not the i
think it's the first of many right
and uh i think you were right and i was
right
at the same time you're both definitely
right 100 i'm glad i'm glad that we were
both right
so is your wife too i'm sure i'm sure
yeah we are yeah we're pretty excited
about it
oh man um congratulations
on getting the money you deserve and the
respect that that money that money
brings
um what was that like for you did you
literally just tap out and let your
agent handle it or
were you part of this process george oh
i know i was definitely
very involved with the process you know
luckily my agent uh you know jackie
did a good job of uh he kind of informed
us you know from about a year ago just
how the process was going the things
that you know
we would be interested in you know like
i don't i didn't do all the words and
stuff like that you know
in that part of the contract but just
knowing that the structure of the set
of the contract itself is what was
interesting to me so being involved with
process was fun
um and i really enjoyed it so i mean
just learning about that side of the
side of the game was was pretty exciting
for me and um
i will say i'm glad that it's over
because it's pretty stressful sometimes
but um
overall i'm pretty glad that it's over
and uh i was just happy that you know we
got to work together and
get the thing done and so both sides are
happy yeah i i got to admit to you
george uh you know i've been in contract
negotiations for me from my profession
um i feel like i have a similar game at
the microphone that you have
as a tight end if i may say so um
okay thank you well i mean you know i
gotta speak it into existence to use the
phrase
um but i cannot recall ever
using the word fun to describe a
negotiation i i would never
associate that word with it in a million
years i just more
i just more like the learning process
behind it of like what actually goes
into making a contract
i just thought that was really
interesting like um just
whether it was the structure of the
contract like just learning about the
apy
the guarantees and all that stuff just
how it all worked and how it flowed
together
uh it made a lot more sense to me than
just you know hey
don't just look at one big number you
want to look at the things in the back
that you know
maybe not everyone wants to see and so
it was just fun being able to learn
about that whole process
george kittle here on the rich eisen
show just a few weeks ago
i said that you know if there's such a
thing as winning the offseason i
i said your team did you know obviously
the chiefs um
you know no offense of giving you a run
for your money by getting the homes
under contract and their general manager
but you know your team got your general
manager under contract and you uh you
had a great draft and obviously
getting you under contract and trent
williams to me was
you know lost in the draft shuffle what
what does he look like
in practice george hey rich i'll tell
you this right he uh
i don't have to play very well and when
we play next to each other it's still
going to look really good
that's pretty fun he's like you know
like you you work on your double teams
like doubling and defensive end up to a
linebacker
i don't know if he needs me to block
both of them no kidding that's what's so
cool
so it's i'm just i feel like i'm just
like the icing on top when it comes to
any time i block with him
it's really cool it's uh he makes my job
easy he's incredibly fast
he's just fun to be in a huddle with too
i just appreciate his knowledge and
just how much like the game means them
you can just see it every single time he
steps on the field
so he's he's done great in our locker
room and i i know it's gonna be really
fun to play with him all year
what is it like being in a huddle in the
covered 19 era my friend
what in the world is that like um
well i mean honestly it's not that
different you know with the
just getting in the facility with all
the testing and all that and like the
regulations we keep you know
six feet apart with our desks and you
wear a mask the whole day and
that's kind of weird but you know when
you're on the football field you still
gotta play football and
you know they they monitor us with like
trackers to see you know you know how
close we are to people for
like the duration of time uh which is
interesting but you know
it just feels good to be back in nfl
huddle i will say that just
it's just like um some real like it just
feels normal and it's it's just fun to
feel that again
well i mean you had one of your
teammates uh at the forefront of
conversations on behalf of the union
with the league on everything
um in richard sherman um and do you all
together from richard to
the rest of your team feel like
everything is being done
to keep you guys safe are you are you
cool with
everything that's uh been laid out and
is that you're going through right now
as a professional george oh yeah i think
what we're doing right now i
i think the regulations that you know
and i can't speak for other teams
i know people are doing it differently
in other places but i think what we're
doing right now is incredible
um you know this the testing like to get
guys into the building the amount of
testing it takes them to how many days
they have to clear
um they do such a great job with the
distance seen and you know we have
they really they've outfitted the entire
facility
you know for this i mean they've made it
as normal as possible which has been
really fun and
it's kind of cool because they're using
different parts of our facilities too so
like
we have a meeting room that's in our
press box you know just for space and
it's just
seeing like how hard they work to make
it safe for us is it's really fun i mean
it's incredible to see honestly just
because of how much hard work went into
it so
i do i do feel safe i know a lot of the
other guys feel safe okay does that give
you
uh a better uh appreciation of the press
that how high up
they stick the press to watch the games
and they're able to be
to do their jobs a little better
appreciation george for you
uh you know sometimes and i i might feel
that um
but i know honestly i just sit back i'm
like hey you know what it's a great view
so it isn't it is its way it's high up
there man
they put the press way up way up there
so i mean i'm i'm
obviously having a little fun with it
but you know the question i get tons of
questions
all the time what do i think do i think
that there's going to be a football
season how is it going to work uh i get
a ton of it you must as well
i basically give the answer of from what
i'm hearing
you are living it do you think that the
way that this is
constructed and the plan that you think
that there
will be a week one through 17 regular
season
in the nfl george
i think it all depends on how seriously
the teams and the players take it
um no you gotta you gotta kind of
shut off some of the outside
distractions you know more than you
would in a normal season
um and it's going to definitely change
the livelihoods of a lot of people in
the nfl
um but you just i mean i guess at the
end of the day you have to be
responsible and you know hey if you want
to play football then you have to follow
these rules and
you can't ruin it for anyone else and i
think if all the teams and all the
players do that
oh 100 i think there's going to be a
season i know there's variables with
traveling in hotels and stuff like that
but the way that we've had it set up
here is uh i mean it gives me a lot of
faith that it could actually get done
yeah i mean that's part of the answer
what i have you very you're very
uh you chose your words very very well
again you're a smart big ten guy
um so it's just that if everybody
uh when they go home stay safe
however you want to um describe that
stay safe that
obviously there will be kids who may go
to school or go out and vectors are
brought into the house and
i think the testing that the way that
the nfl is setting out might
you know should catch it okay they
should be able to identify
who might be asymptomatic in that nature
but it is
your co some of your colleagues who
might just decide to say screw it i'm
gonna still have a social life
and live my life in that manner have you
had a conversation
uh amongst the team about knocking that
off
for the lack of a better phrase george i
think one of the best things that our
team did um
in our head of player development um our
personnel guys ben
he uh he had a uh he like tell stories
like hey for example
let's just say um tripp williams you
want to you know
go to a bar and you get a drink and then
you come back and
we don't test you right like you get
tested on the results for 24 hours
and you actually end up testing
positively don't know it yet how many
people have you talked to
you know in the last 24 hours that have
now you know potentially been infected
and so like he's
they're using stories like a real you
know example so like hey if you talk to
eight people
those eight guys can't play in a
football game if it's on us like friday
night
because it's a 48 hour window and so
it's just like it kind of makes it real
like hey like you have to
change the way you're living otherwise
you're going to put other guys at risk
that are taking it seriously
and i think that's that's a
responsibility and i think guys don't
want to put other guys at risk and so i
think
our team's doing a great job with that
so far and you know i've just been
really
you know um it's been really cool to see
the progress that a lot of guys have
made this like
understanding that process and um like i
said i think it's going really well so
far george kittle few minutes left with
the san francisco 49ers tight end here
on the rich eisen show couldn't help but
notice you get your contract we're
talking about it there's a lot of buzz
and then k
and then kelsey signs his later that day
did do you think he did that on purpose
george to take some of your thoughts
yeah but he's like
my contract i told my contract kettle
signs says i want to steal some of his
thunder
do you think he did it sounds like this
very well that was very odd timing
george
i think oh it's not it's just tight ends
getting the work done together that's
all it is no it's
all about the national you're all about
the national tight ends day man i love
it 24 7 365.
every day's titled it is you kidding me
like and
you know what travis has done for the
position and then um
i think kind of together we kind of you
know kicked a hole uh you know right in
the ceiling you know about you know how
tight it should get paid and i
just it's awesome and i think it's just
going to continue to set the tone and
set the tone and
um i just love the fact that titans are
getting recognition that they deserve
because it is such a difficult position
maybe that's why maybe that's why gronk
came back george what do you think
he's sick and tired of seeing you and
kelsey's set the table like that
i think he just wants to you know be a
part of the national tight end again
because you know it is his grog spike is
the logo so i think he has a banana oh
that's right
i totally forgot about that well again i
know the details rich you know i just i
should you know i'm i'm a little punter
focused but you know that i'm coming
around though
[Laughter]
i'm slowly coming around george okay so
uh all right so
you think everything is set up for a
season that's so damn exciting man and
then your schedule
uh you're you're going to spend a it
looks like a couple
of your back-to-back games in uh in the
same stadium are you gonna set up shop
in new york for weeks two and three is
that the way you're
you guys are are discussing it right now
oh no i
you don't know yet i don't know i know
what we did last year when we went to
i think we played at the ravens at new
orleans so we just stayed in florida for
the whole
for that week in between which was nice
we didn't have to fly five hours back
and i'm assuming that we might do the
same thing and i know a lot of like i
love that what we did last year because
you'd have to fly and you got to stand
the east coast in that time zone which
was awesome
um so i mean i hope we do it i don't
know
um but you know i don't know the
difficulties of doing it you know just
in today's you know day and age and so
but i'm open to it and if we can work it
out i love it
george i'm i'm so thrilled you called in
today and you know
uh you're really one of my favorites and
you know i
it's true you you came on this show last
year you're like i want to time you for
your run
i you know i'm like great i'll i'll
reach out i did
you did it you came you were part of the
the run rich run you know with jerry
rice so it was 49er greats in the past
and the present
and just you being present and talking
to
vaughn the eight-year-old who was there
recovering from uh brain surgery
and making his day even more special and
then adding to the cause
you're really a special human george and
i want everyone to know that if they
already didn't that's a fact
thank you rich i really appreciate that
you know i saw that the timer that i
timed on is still on
when he signed for me
okay blazing fast well you know what
george i please
i appreciate you adding that adjective
of blazing i appreciate that
i love it i love it and that was great
and um
you know it feels like years ago with
what's going on in the real world but uh
i just wanted to
get you on the show and i appreciate you
being on the first peacock show and
hopefully it's the first of many times
you take care of yourself
hey man congratulations thanks brother
so sick i really
yeah it's awesome you know i love you
and i know my dad does too so
yeah i really appreciate it send my best
to send my best to all the kids you take
care of yourself george we'll
we'll chat down the line yep see you
guys you got it it's george kittle at g
kittle 46
on instagram and twitter or did not like
that guy
oh